pour mon compte donc sur la masse
globale les tout petits pourront pas
bougé
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
en soir vient de l'ignorance aujourd'hui
une gauche extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
après un échange avec emmanuel macron
c'est avec joe biden que le vadimir
poutine s'est entretenu par téléphone au
coeur des discussions toujours la
situation en ukraine les tensions se
sont ravivées ces dernières heures la
russie accusée par washington d'une
invasion imminente de son voisin
ni séries américaines à l'apogée kiev
critique de son côté des annonces qui
suscite la panique
[Musique]
contre le patin vaccinale et plus
largement contre le gouvernement alors
que les convois de la liberté se
dirigeait vers paris une partie de ces
milliers d'opposants ont réussi à
rejoindre les champs elysées mobilisés
hier les forces de l'ordre les ont
dispersés 44 personnes ont été
interpellées compte rendu de cette
journée mobilisation dans un instant
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
après que moscou a annoncé de nouvelles
manoeuvres militaires à la frontière une
trentaine de navires de la flotte russe
sont pris la mer ce samedi dans le cadre
d'exercices maritime en mer noire
washington affirme craindre une
offensive militaire russe contre
l'ukraine catégoriquement démentie par
la russie les états unis qui vont
envoyer quelques 3000 soldats
supplémentaires en pologne il avait
avancé ce vendredi qu'une invasion
pouvait être imminente accusation
qualifiée de provocatrice par le kremlin
des propos qui provoque la panique et
n'aident pas les ukrainiens dénonce de
son côté leur présidence de lenski
échanges diplomatiques au sommet donc ce
samedi vladimir poutine s'est entretenu
par téléphone avec emmanuel macron puis
joe biden on retrouve à moscou notre
correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
bonsoir verra un entretien de près de
deux heures avec le président français
puis plus d'une heure avec le président
américain cette fois ci quelle a été la
teneur de ces échanges verra
bonsoir se fit effectivement beaucoup de
tractations diplomatiques ce samedi
temps sur leur comble dans le dossier
ukrainien après l'annoncé par plusieurs
médias américains de la date exacte de
l'invasion supposé russe de l'ukraine
selon politico qui se réfère aux sauces
de la maison blanche la russie prévoit
une attaque le 16 février quand l agence
bloomberg elle évoque le 15 février que
tous les conseillers américains la
sécurité nationale jake sullivan qui a
estimé que l'invasion était prévu avant
la fin des g aux jeux olympiques au à
pékin c'est à dire avant le 20 février
lors de leur conversation téléphonique
jo baden et a prévenu vladimir poutine
que la russie allait faire face à des
conséquences graves de la part des états
unis et de leurs alliés en cas
d'escaladé l'ukraine et concernant la
partie russe le kremlin dénoncé une
hystérie américaine à l'apogée après
l'appel des présidents mais quand même
les deux présidents se sont mis d'accord
pour poursuivre le dialogue le président
oui s'est également entretenu avec son
homologue français l'entrevue
téléphonique a duré 1h40
selon le kremlin les deux présidents
discuter de la situation les aux
spéculations provocatrice quant à une
prétendue invasion russe de l'ukraine
qui s'accompagne de livraison d'ampleur
d'armements modernes à ce pays je vous
propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine a de nouveau attiré
l'attention sur l'absence de réponse
substantielle de la part des états unis
et de l'otan aux initiatives russes bien
connu il a souligné la réticence des
principaux pays occidentaux a poussé les
autorités de kiev à mettre en oeuvre les
accords de minsk ce qui s'est une
nouvelle fois manifesté lors de la série
de consultations des conseillers
politiques des dirigeants des états du
format normandie qui s'est tenu sans
résultat le 10 février à berlin compte
rendu de l'elysée le président français
a fait savoir à son homologue russe
qu'un dialogue sincère et n'étaient pas
compatibles avec une escalade militaire
à la frontière russo ukrainienne
toujours d'après la présidence française
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine ont
tous deux exprimé une volonté de
poursuivre le dialogue sur les voies
pour avancer sur la mise en oeuvre des
accords de misc sur le doubs basse et
sur les accords de la sécurité et la
stabilité en europe
merci beaucoup verhaeghe hoffman en
direct de moscou sur le terrain à l'est
de l'ukraine dans le donbass les
autorités de la république autoproclamée
de donetsk redoutent une offensive d'une
offensive de kiev elle s'inquiète de la
concentration militaire le long de la
ligne de contact la situation et
électriques récit de notre envoyé
spécial antoine clermont
en milieu d'après-midi le bruit d'une
explosion a pu être entendue dans
plusieurs quartiers de deux nièces sur
internet et des rumeurs ont couru comme
quoi cette explosion avait eu lieu dans
le centre ville mais très rapidement les
autorités locales ont fait savoir que ce
n'était pas le cas mais c'est une
explosion qui avait eu lieu au niveau de
la ligne de contact par contre je peux
vous raconter la façon dont j'ai vécu
les événements j'étais alors assis un
café et au moment de l'explosion s'était
en fait un bruit sourd et lointain et
bien lieu comme une pause les gens se
sont regardés ont regardé par la fenêtre
il ya eu des ossements des pôles et très
rapidement les gens ont repris le fil de
leurs conversations cela montre bien
d'après moi la façon dont tous ces gens
ont intégré le bruit de ces explosions
ils font partie de la vie quotidienne
alors plus globalement nous sommes allés
à la rencontre de ces gens un peu plus
tôt dans la journée ils nous ont raconté
la façon dont ils vivent cette escalade
des tensions
moi je ne sens rien ma famille est calme
je suis médecin est là où je travaille
ça va mais en fait une certaine angoisse
se fait sentir
au chien en réalité je crois que comme
n'importe quelle personne qui vit tout
simplement ici l'essentiel ce n'est pas
ce qu'on dit mais ce qui se passe en
réalité
à présent il n'y a pas d'aggravation
dont on parle dieu merci espérons que ça
continuera comme ça
cela me préoccupe mais je sais que les
gars qui nous protège ici ne laisserons
personne nous attaquer
ce sont des nouvelles très triste qui ne
nous rendent pas du tout on souhaiterait
de la stabilité mais bien sûr la
diffusion de ces nouvelles nous rend
tristes
malgré cet état de vives tensions la pu
entendre plusieurs appels au calme comme
celui lancé par le ministère ukrainien
des affaires étrangères par contre sur
le terrain on le sent très bien se
calmer tout à fait relatif et décryptage
à présent avec karine bêcher golovkov
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce soir les etats-unis sommes
l'alertent depuis des semaines
maintenant sur une offensive imminente
de la russie vers l'ukraine on l'a vu
les propos se sont donc fait plus
alarmiste encore ces dernières 24 heures
quelle est la posture la des américains
et comment selon vous réagissent les
russes en retour eux qui démentent
depuis des semaines toutes velléités
offensives
dont soit effectivement nous avons vu
ces derniers temps une accélération de
la posture agressive américaine qui
semble avoir la tentation de
effectivement provoquer un scénario
militaire je dis bien provoquer parce
qu'il n'est pas évident du tout qu'ils
interviennent directement en fait
d'après le renseignement militaire
russes il y aurait de nombreux groupes
djihadistes qui vont débarquer sur la
ligne de fond côté ukrainien et l'on
peut craindre effectivement qu'il y ait
des provocations qui soient mises en
oeuvre maintenant il faut comprendre que
ces provocations ont une chance d'être
réalisé si les états unis ont la
certitude que la russie n'interviendra
pas pour défendre le donbass parce que
soyons très clairs si les états unis ont
envie de gagner cette guerre très
concrètement et de récupérer
physiquement le territoire du dombass
ils n'ont pas envie de mener cette
guerre donc beaucoup va dépendre aussi
de l'attitude de la russie qui jusqu'à
présent en tout cas aujourd'hui
a parfaitement tenu l'espèce d'assaut
diplomatique qui a été menée par les
chancelleries occidentales
et sans le résister et plus sa position
sera forte et plus il y aura des chances
que se confirmer n'ait pas lieu pour
washington les manoeuvres militaires de
la russie sont le signe de la
préparation d'une opération russe en
ukraine où washington qui répond donc en
envoyant des soldats américains dans les
pays alliés de l'otan quel est votre
regard
de la même manière dans ce cas là on
peut considérer que la présence
militaire étrangère en ukraine et
programmes de l'otan les nombreuses
manoeuvres à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres de chez eux que font ces
militaires aux frontières de la russie
sont un signe d'agression crochets des
pays de l'otan vers la russie donc
soyons un peu sérieux on ne va pas non
plus tourner les choses à l'extrême il
ya effectivement un rapport de force
chacun montre ses muscles 1 mais la
décision du conflit face à face n'a pas
encore été prise même si manifestement
la tentation côte est américaine devient
très très importante deux entretiens
téléphoniques donc pour vladimir poutine
dans la journée avec emmanuel macron
puis joe biden est ce que la désescalade
et la baisse des tensions à est possible
comment est ce que vous voyez
l'évolution de la situation dans les
prochaines heures les prochains jours
d'une manière ou d'une autre il va bien
falloir que cette montée en puissance en
quelque sorte abouti sur quelque chose
parce que nous assistons effectivement
ces dernières 24 heures à une poussée
extrême de 6 que ressemble réellement à
une opération spéciale l'on voit
effectivement que la diplomatie est
devenue un instrument de guerre en tout
cas dans la stratégie américaine et sur
quoi cela va-t-il débouchés les pays
européens ont ici un rôle sérieux joue
et puisque il n'est absolument pas du
tout de leur intérêt de voir a confirmé
se débloquer aux frontières et il me
semble que jusqu'à présent
malheureusement le passage je ne veux
pas parler du passage de la diplomate
britannique
mais en tout cas disons que
nos chefs d'états nos diplomaties
européennes manifestement ne sont pas à
la hauteur et c'est extrêmement rare la
dame parce que ils ont réellement un
rôle à jouer rappelant que l'intérêt est
justement de garder des relations
pacifiques avec la russie qui ne cherche
pas un conflit armé avec qui ne cherche
pas un conflit avec eux mais au
contraire une coopération et l'intérêt
de des pays européens n'est pas d'être
instrumentalisés dans un jeu atlantiste
et globalisme et c'est justement de
défendre les intérêts de l'europe et
c'est l'occasion peut-être de le montrer
seront ils à la hauteur pour l'instant
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas on
l'a vu en lait pour leurs pourparlers se
multiplient depuis des jours voire des
semaines entre moscou et les occidentaux
américains autant un pays européen où
est-ce que ça bloque aujourd'hui
toujours sur le même point ça bloque
toujours sur le même point parce que
nous sommes dans une logique de conflit
nous sommes pas dans une logique
réellement diplomatique j'ai dit la
diplomatie ici est utilisé comme un
instrument de combat donc le problème
est que il ne peut pas y avoir de
objectivement et c'est vrai il peut pas
y avoir de consensus d'un côté ou de
l'autre puisque tout compromis serait
une défaite on ne peut pas à la fois
acceptée à montreux globaliste et ce qui
est posée par les états unis est laissée
à la russie le droit d'avoir un intérêt
vital et de le défendre la firme et et
la russie ne peut pas à la fois défendre
sa souveraineté est acceptée l'intérêt
globalise de la même manière que le don
bassin se retrouve pris entre ces deux
de conflit puisque d'un côté les accords
de mise certes ont été conclu il ya sept
ans depuis le temps a passé la situation
de complètement différente il n'est pas
certain du tout que la population dans
le donbass est envie de revenir dans le
cren après avoir été pendant sept ans
prise en otage par pièce par kiev et
agressé donc il y à une impasse en
quelque sorte et il va falloir à un
moment donné réellement se poser la
question est ce que cela vaut la peine
d'une guerre puisque n'oublions pas
quand même que la guerre au delà
peut-être du côté romantique intéressant
que les conseillers des byden
peuvent-ils trouver c'est la mort de
personne c'est la destruction de pays
échappaient la destruction des
civilisations à mon avis cela mérite
quand même d'y réfléchir merci beaucoup
pour votre regard karine bcgo love
qu'aux professeurs en vitesse à
l'université d'état de moscou
parti de toute la france vendredi il
avait pour objectif de rallier paris
aujourd'hui et avant de rejoindre
bruxelles lundi pour une convergence
européenne
plusieurs véhicules des convois de la
liberté sont parvenus à entrer dans la
capitale malgré un important dispositif
policier l'interdiction décrétée par la
préfecture sept mille six cents
manifestants au total à paris selon le
ministère de l'intérieur notre reporter
david khalifa a suivi la mobilisation il
était sur les champs-elysées en fin de
journée
malgré l'interdiction de manifester
maintenue par le tribunal administratif
hier soir le convoi de la liberté a
réussi à s'introduire au sein même de la
capitale pour exprimer à sa colère a
dénoncé les restrictions sanitaires
mettre fin aux passes vaccinale et a
dénoncé également le comportement du
gouvernement totalement déconnectés de
la réalité depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire qu'ils étaient plusieurs
centaines à venir à exprimer cette
colère sur l'avenue adf champs elysées
c'était inespéré pour eux pour ces gens
qui viennent de toute la france dans ce
convoi de la liberté pour atteindre la
capitale est pour vous et pour pouvoir
entrer au sein même de paris au vu du
dispositif de sécurité mis en place par
le préfet à didier lallement un qui est
dans la continuité du gouvernement avait
annoncé être inflexible et ferme face à
ce mouvement sept mille deux cents
gendarmes et policiers ont été déployés
au sein de la capitale ça n'a pas
empêché à force de persuasion de
détermination ces manifestants du convoi
de la liberté à pouvoir atteindre la vie
des champs elysées on dénombre à peu
près 350 verbalisation 1,44
interpellation à 17h 30 ans de la part
des forces de l'ordre puisque l'avenue
des champs elysées a été le théâtre de
violents affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre un
nuage de gaz lacrymogène a envahi les
champs elysées un tout au long de cet
après midi le calme est revenu vers
17h30 ici même sur cette avenue
l'objectif était de disperser évidemment
tous ces manifestants présents sur les
champs-elysées qui voulaient bloquer la
circulation afin d'exprimer leur colère
et dénoncer les restrictions un
sanitaire ces mesures restrictives qui
sont des atteintes à la liberté alors
notamment à la liberté de pouvoir vivre
sereinement mais aussi à la liberté
d'expression puisque je vous le disais
un le tribunal administratif a confirmé
il y à l'interdiction de pouvoir
manifester pour ce convoi de la liberté
beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de joie et
surtout un soulagement de pouvoir
atteindre paris sur cette avenue des
champs-elysées je vous repose dans
l'écouté quelques-uns alors je suis venu
parce que pour notre liberté pour
respecter nos droits fondamentaux et
j'ai beaucoup aimé les différentes
phases du voyage parce que hier par
exemple à 3 c'était mémorable et je suis
surprise de voir qu'à paris tout est
beaucoup plus compliquées alors que le
pacifisme et est de rigueur j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya pas eu de boue il
n'y a pas eu de débordement et pourtant
tout de suite on a vu les forces de
l'ordre arrivées débarqué je crois qu'on
arrive à une saturation on arrive à
aussi un arrogant c'est une provocation
qui devient g devient insupportable
surtout
entre les changements permanents de
situations et de mesure et d'arrières se
passe
vaccinale maintenant moi je dirais qu'on
est content pour compenser pas sanitaire
au pass vaccinale mais que la plupart
des gens ne sont pas dupes on tend vers
un citoyen c'est-à-dire videmment
contrôle de plus en plus les gens c'est
une réalité c'est pas du tout du
complotisme c'est ce sont des faits
c'est factuel marquer le coup pour les
convoyeurs c'était l'objectif principal
de cette journée l'idée est de faire une
convergence européenne ce lundi 14
février à bruxelles pour pouvoir
continuer à dénoncer les restrictions
sanitaires et les mesures restrictives
mises en place par l'exécutif depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
et figure de gilet jaune jérôme
rodriguez fait partie des personnes
interpellées par les forces de l'ordre à
paris nous sommes en direct avec son
avocat david libeskind
bonsoir merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt francs
sur quels motifs précisément gérard
rodriguez at il été interpellés
alors il ya trois personnes qui ont été
interpellées dont jérôme rodriguez est
une personne qui m'a désigné alors sur
quel motif organisation d'une
manifestation non déclarée ce qui est
complètement ridicule puisqu'il se
trouvait ces trois personnes se trouvent
à proximité de la rue saint-honoré
n'était pas inséré dans une
manifestation
évidemment comme je redemande rugueuse
et ciblée en permanence par les forces
de l'ordre ils ont procédé à leur
arrestation sans aucune raison voilà le
motif ces organisation d'une
manifestation non déclarée mais
évidemment
lavez pas en fête organisé une
quelconque manifestation pour agacer
revendiqué sur les réseaux sociaux comme
l'un des organisateurs du convoi de la
liberté convoi qui avait été interdite
par la préfecture de police de paris
alors jérôme rodriguez ne sait jamais en
fait organique est comme un corps
organisateurs du convoi de la liberté il
a dit qu'il soutenait en fait ce convoi
de la liberté et rendez vous compte
qu'il était par la rue saint-honoré ils
étaient trois personnes dont elle n'est
pas du tout dans le mouvement en fait du
convoi de la liberté lady juste là pour
la levée ce qui est complètement son
droit en france on n'interdit pas aux
gens de simples citoyens de filmer voilà
deux films de l'arrivée mais était que
trois personnes et je le répète alors
qu'il a été interpellé organisait pour
organisation d'une manifestation non
déclarée il n'a faire en fait que
relayer comme il le fait habituellement
furcy live un événement là en
l'occurrence le combat pour la liberté
mais en aucun cas ces essais à
l'organisateur est ce que vous avez pu
entrer en contact avec l'ios qu'elle se
trouve ce soir
alors là alors là je là je suis à porte
maillot le commissariat vient de
m'appeler donc là je me rends au
commissariat de police du 7ème
arrondissement puisque les trois
personnes qui ont été interpellées une
manière abusive ce en garde à vue au
commissariat de police du 7ème donc là
j'allais juste me rendre quoi et quelles
vont être les prochaines étapes dans ce
dossier
dans la prochaine étape déjà c'est
l'entretien avec la personne qui m'a dit
en garde à vue et ensuite il va avoir
les auditions mais compte tenu que
l'infraction qui est reprochée puni
d'une peine d'emprisonnement
inférieure à un an lagarde amis ne peut
duré que 24 heures donc au bout de 24
heures plusieurs solutions soit il
relâchait ramon rodriguez les personnes
amis qu'ils étaient vous soyez différé
au parquet votre miel de tissi mais là
en l'état n'ayant pas tous les éléments
d'information
je ne vois pas en fait pour quel motif
il sera déferré c'est juste en fait de
la pression psychologique de la
répression policière je prends clients
depuis trois ans en fait les
manifestants notamment jérôme on indiqué
sont ciblés et souvent en fait ce sont
des personnes qui sont arrêtés qui sont
complices ont relâchés après avoir
déféré au parquet on essaye en fait de
faire à leur encontre de la violence
psychologique
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france david lee
boskin l'un des avocats de jérôme
rodriguez
à deux mois de la présidentielle ce
nouveau mouvement de protestation des
convois de la liberté dans la lignée de
celui des gels et jaune comme explique
matthieu cocq responsable du pôle
politique et aussi longtemps que le
milite le millénaire
ils voient qu'on est lent qu'on a là en
face de nous un mouvement un mouvement
social est un mouvement politique qui
n'est et qui s'inscrit un petit peu dans
le continuum de ce qu'ont été les gilet
jaune en 2018 2019 ce mouvement qui
s'est déclarée de fait comme les gilet
jaune à politique refusant l'arrêt la
récupération et dont les figures
inspirante n'était non pas les élites
politiques est plutôt des personnalités
de la société civile on pense aux roux
professeur didier rahout et c'est ce que
les manifestants on scandé sur les sur
les champs-elysées est-ce qu'il
s'inscrira dans le temps par rapport au
canada c'est à voir mais en tout cas le
premier point qu'on peut on peut mettre
en avant ses sept c'est cette dimension
apolitique qui va ensuite avoir des
répercussions potentielles sur la
campagne présidentielle
lé convoi de la liberté ont été rejoints
en fin de journée par certains
manifestants ont qui passe sanitaires
comme chaque samedi ils se rassemblent à
l'appel du candidat les patriotes à la
présidentielle florian à la
présidentielle florian philippot hélène
masse colis étaient dans le cortège
aujourd'hui un défilé dans une ambiance
très festive de ce côté de la capitale
le cortège est arrivée un peu plus tôt
ici devant le ministère de la santé dans
le calme avec de très nombreux
manifestants qui ont répondu à l'appel
de florian philippot certains sont même
venus via le convoi de la liberté ils
sont partis de marseille de montpellier
de lille ou encore de strasbourg ils
étaient tous là pour dénoncer les
restrictions sanitaires du gouvernement
le port du masque le vaccin obligatoire
le pass le vaccinale qu'il nomme le pass
de la honte des mesures qu'ils jugent
tout liberticide et pourtant il ya trois
jours le porte parole du gouvernement
gabonais à laval annoncé la possible
levée du pass vaccinale fin mars début
avril mais pour florian philippot il ne
s'agit ni plus ni moins qu'une manoeuvre
politique ce jeu que les parker ce
gouvernement qui a déjà supprimé des
choses puis remis juste derrière et là
on est surtout à dijon une élection
présidentielle début avril donc ils se
moquent de nous en fait il va suspendre
le patac sinal alors que le seuil ne
s'est jamais justifié le suspens
pourquoi il attend dix jours avant ils
sont payants ciel et puis il a dit la
levée il n'y a pas dit l'abrogation
celle-ci magron repas ce qu'on a le
droit de nouveau on le sait bien à cette
société du pass vaccinale des qr codes
et j'en veux pas moi donc on chez
mobilis pas que compte le pas axial
depuis le début on se mobilise pour
éviter de tomber dans un monde de
surveillance et de contrôle un monde de
qr code l'homme que comac rompt avec sa
clique veut absolument nous imposer on
le refuse totalement cette nouvelle
mobilisation était aussi l'occasion pour
le candidat à la présidentielle de
présenter son programme avec en premier
lieu le fch exit la sortie de la france
de l'union européenne mais en attendant
le mois d'avril un seul mot d'ordre pour
le chef de file des patriotes résistance
jusqu'au bout avec un nouvel appel à se
mobiliser dès samedi prochain
et retour à présent sur le web n'a au
charme ce mythe rencontre internationale
qui s'est tenue pendant trois jours à
brest autour d' emmanuel macron une
trentaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ils ont promis d'en faire
plus pour protéger les océans
indispensable à la régulation du climat
et riches en biodiversité une avancée
saluée par les ong mais elle attendait
plus tu es au combat
aucune image qui se veut marquantes une
trentaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement se sont rassemblés durant
trois jours à brest afin de montrer leur
mobilisation pour la protection des
océans vous l'avez dit
nous allons aujourd'hui prendre des
engagements ce seront les engagements de
brest ils vont permettre de consolider
des actions utiles jean s'est convaincu
et un agenda international essentiel
pour l'année 2022 parmi ces traits
engagement on retrouve notamment la
création de nouvelles aires protégées
le renforcement de la lutte contre la
pêche illégale la volonté de relancer un
accord mondial destiné à la protection
de la haute mer ou encore l'engagement
de l'unesco a cartographié au moins 80%
des fonds marins d'ici à 2030 des
mesures largement insuffisante pour les
ong qui oeuvre à la protection des
océans alors nous quand on entend one
aux chaînes smi tandis que c'est un
sommet pour préserver l'océan
malheureusement quand on regarde le
bilan de cette première édition on est
plutôt sur un sommet sur l'exploitation
de l'océan donc on parle d'énergie bleue
d'économie bleus on a très peu parlé de
la surpêche on n'a pas parlé de choses
fondamentales sur une protection
effective et réelle en termes d re
marines protégées donc en fait on est
passé complètement à côté du sujet et
presque en fait on glorifie l'énergie
bleue comme si c'était quelque chose qui
était en faveur de l'océan preuve que
nous au dossier reste encore à traiter
la france et le costa rica organiserons
ensemble la prochaine conférence des
nations unies sur l'océan en 2024 des
prises de décisions trop longue pour de
nombreuses ong
selon la fondation ellen macarthur les
océans pourraient contenir plus de
plastique queue de poisson d'ici à 2050
si rien n'est fait
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actu à 21h à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi elle s'est
tournée vers le communisme il pensait
que la gauche s'étaient vendus il se
disait la démocratie la démocratie
sociale ne fait pas le travail et il a
vu l'avènement d'hitler en allemagne
donc il regardait l'union soviétique
comme un bastion anti fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait briller
[Musique]
les banques vont elles vraiment bien
pouvons-nous avoir confiance en elles
sommes-nous à l'abri et à quel point ce
sentiment d'insécurité que nous pouvons
tous avoir des légitimes aujourd'hui les
banques ne sont pas des endroits où on
est plus en sécurité qu'on ne l'était en
2007 peu importe la connerie que la
banque d'affaires personne ne sera
jamais puni si je gérais une entreprise
d'une taille comme grandes banques
françaises sans les nommer de la même
manière on m'aurait fait déposer deux
mille ans déjà depuis commandes à faire
alors pour protéger nos économies pour
ce qu'ils peuvent évidemment il faut
dresser des banques la risée mes parents
ou d'autres personnes qui ont dit milou
15000 euros sur leur contrat ils vont
vous ils peuvent aller acheter dès lors
elle est achetée de une autre monnaie
aujourd'hui c'est eux des banques à
reese et ben non pour faire le que les
courses au super u bas il me faut ma
carte qui me font mon compte donc sur la
masse globale les tout petits pourront
pas bougé
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]